Oh, sorry.
Sorry for all the loops.
Oh, did I say loop?
What if we have a fifth loop?
Not a fifth loop.
Sorry, guys.
I am, like, trying to, like, mentally prepare myself for, um, the fight that I have to do.
Where past Doki has left me.
I realized what boss past Doki has left me with, which is apparently one of the harder bosses.
And, um, and also, I'm, like, okay, not gonna lie, I'm actually very socially drained right now.
I'm so... oh, my gosh.
All the back-to-back-to-back-to-back collabs I've done the last... I don't know.
The streak has been... it was a long streak of collabs, but, like, I am very... I am very, like, drained.
My social battery is so low now.
Um, yeah, I've been doing a lot the last X amount of weeks since...
Oh, since the beginning of July, I believe, right?
Wait, no, it was even before July.
Since, like, August.
I've been trying to keep up the streak, but, um, I am... I'm, like, running on fumes right now.
I had to... I was literally after the... after the Marvel sponsor, I was just, like, sitting at my desk, just staring at the wall.
I was so tired.
I... I was so... I was so tired.
Um...
Because of that.
And, like, tomorrow, I also have another sponsor.
I have another sponsor tomorrow.
Uh... Oh, wait, August is after July.
What?
I mean, June.
Since before June.
Today's August!
Oh, my gosh!
Fuck!
Okay, I... I told you guys, my brain is not okay right now.
I'm super fucking fried right now.
And then since June, I've been collabing, like, with someone at least once a week.
And, um, if you guys didn't know, I am an introvert, and I do need time to charge up my social battery.
But I have not had that time to charge at all.
So, I'm just... I'm, like, my... I...
To be fair, in the morning, I was telling my manager, in the morning, um, my brain was so, like, overwhelmed when I woke up.
I didn't know why.
I was, like, when I woke up, I just felt, like, this overwhelming feeling.
Um, I think I was just tired.
I was very tired before the stream started, too.
I didn't want to say it on stream, because I was, like, okay, you're sponsored, Doki.
And, like, the Marvel Rival does always treat you so good, so you got...
Put on your game face, Doki!
Uh, but I was so tired, um, before the stream started.
Um, and, uh, um, and tomorrow, I actually have, uh, have another sponsored collab stream.
Wait, what's this?
What's this over here?
Uh, uh, oh, okay, sorry.
I got, like, a text message being, like, remember to give dad his vaccine.
His vaccine's rent, uh, is expiring.
Um, because I was, like, your dog's health is important.
I was, like, why?
I was, like, oh my god, what happened?
And then they're, like, oh, remember to update your vaccine?
I was, like, what happened?
Because he's at a dog center right now.
So, I got baited to look at the text.
But it was literally, like, my, my family...
My, sorry, not family.
I mean, dad is family.
My, my main vet being, like, you gotta make sure that he updates his vaccine.
I was, like, okay.
Um, um, but what I was saying.
Oh, yeah.
But, yeah, tomorrow, it's another sponsored stream that's on Twitch.
Um, and it's for Fake Trigger.
Um, so, we're gonna be playing that.
That's gonna be another tournament.
Um, it's, like, a third person.
It's basically, like, PUBG.
PUBG with anime girls.
And abilities, like, uh, Apex slash Valorant.
That's what Fake Trigger is.
So, if you guys ever, if you guys watch any of the gameplay of it.
Um, the rotations for Fake Trigger was basically, like, PUBG.
Where you get a car and then you rotate into, like, zone and positioning.
Yeah, it's Battle Royale.
So, and it's third person.
Um, um, and instead of, like, you know, uh, instead of, like, realistic graphics, it's anime girls.
Uh, so, that's gonna be on Twitch as well.
Uh, because of Twitch drops.
So, I look forward to that tomorrow.
Uh, sure, it's gonna be with Sure4, RPR, and Albert Lele.
So, we're on a team with Sure4 again for tomorrow.
Um, funny thing is that we were all, like, sponsored individually.
And then they grouped all of us together.
Um, so, we didn't, like, we didn't, like, uh, come together as a team.
As in, like, you know, one captain and then selected the rest.
It was literally, like, all four of us were, like, sponsored.
And then you just combine us together into one sponsored team.
Uh, uh, Karami, welcome to Tamiya Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Uh, so, yeah, we're gonna be on group B.
So, apparently, it's, like, there's two groups playing.
But I chose the one at, uh, at a later time.
Because I don't want to wake up at 11 a.m.
Oh, wait, no, I have to wake up.
Fuck.
I have to wake up at 10 a.m.
for my cleaners.
Never mind.
I, I still have to, uh, I still, uh, have to, um, have to wake up early.
Because my cleaner's coming over tomorrow at 10 in the morning.
Um, but, yeah, my social battery is so, I'm, like, not, I don't want to say, I don't want to say burnt out.
I'm not really burnt out, per se.
I'm just very socially drained.
Um, but, so, next week, because I noticed, I've been, like, uh, I know, like, when I'm really tired.
When I'm, like, not as witty as I like to be.
In terms of, like, I'm not very quick with my responses.
Or, um, you know, bringing content and stuff.
Which I've been noticing.
Because, um, I notice when I need a break.
When, after the stream, I'd be, like, Oh, man, why didn't I say that?
Oh, that would have been such a funny joke to say.
Yeah.
Like, after the stream's over, I'd be, like, Oh, my God, I can't believe I didn't say that.
Um, so, that's, like, when I know, like, Oh, I need to rest up.
So, uh, because, like, after the Marvel Rival stream, I was, like, This was a joke that, like, literally came up.
You know how you're, like, uh, when, you know, like, uh, You're, like, with a group of people and they say something mean to you.
And you, like, be, like, okay.
And then, like, after you go home, you're, like, Yeah, well, uh, you're, You're, like, Oh, why did I say that back to her?
Jacob, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Yeah, you're, like, replaying your head.
You're, like, Oh, why did I say that back to her?
Oh, my God, That would've been such a good comeback.
Like, shit like that.
So that was me after my stream.
After my Marvel Vival stream.
And I was like, oh man, why didn't I feel that?
Why didn't I?
Yeah, I'm VOD reviewing my jokes.
Yeah.
I'm looking back at the VOD and I'm like, oh man, at like 5 minutes and 33 seconds, if I said that, that would've been so much funnier and could've got a better reaction and then maybe I would've got clipped more.
Oh, why didn't I say that?
Okay, Jokey, remember this joke for next time.
Anyway, this is a joke that I wrote down because I wanted... from my VOD reviews.
Um, this was a really good joke that I wish I said, so I'm gonna say it now.
I know the timing is very off because we're not playing Marvel Rivals.
But you know how like, Luna Snow got like, another... Yes, I wrote it down!
Because I was like, aww, Doki, that was so clever.
I gotta write that down.
I'm running it back.
I'm running it play-by-play.
So like, you know, okay, so at like, at the beginning of the stream, okay, we're doing play-by-play.
At the beginning of the stream, you know how we were looking at Luna Snow and looking at the abilities that she, like all the buffs she's getting and we were like, oh man, she's so greedy.
I was like, aww, why did I say something like, you get, you're like, you're like, oh, um, when will you be happy, Luna players?
And then I would have been like, I won't be, I'll never be happy until I can kill the entire enemy team and 1v6 everybody.
And that would have been such a good joke.
I'll never be happy.
So clever.
Okay, but I did see someone, um, they were talking about like the Loki, yes, please clap, guys.
Someone was saying how like, uh, Loki, the Loki lamps, uh, when you place it down, um, you can also, and you have a Mantis player, because you need a Mantis player to do the team-up with Loki.
And, um, and you place down the Loki lamps, and you, uh, the lamps actually give everybody a damage boost, and then from there, uh, Mantis can actually stack her damage boost with Loki's damage boost, and then the guy, I think it was Boger, the Boger was like,
uh, that's great, now you can feel, now you can have 1% of Luna's power.
And I was like, oh, that's so true, Luna just gets everything, while every other support player is literally begging for scraps every season.
Luna's just like, like, the favorite child.
By doing a team-up with Loki, you can stack your damage boost with Loki Labs, and then you'll be just as strong as 1% of Luna Snow.
When Adam... you know how long it took Adam to get his first buff?
Like, three fucking updates.
Alright, so, because... because I am feeling really tired lately, when I know, like, I'm running on fumes, I will be taking next week off.
So, next week, there will not... I don't know if there will be in streams, but I will be taking next week off, just because I am feeling like I'm running on fumes right now, and my social battery is very, very low.
That said, I am going to slow down on collabs.
I won't, like, stop collabs.
I might do it, like, every other week instead of every week, because, like, there's too many.
I've been interacting with so many people, and I'm tired.
I'm tired.
I wanna... I wanna do some more solo streams.
Um, so we're gonna change collabs.
I know we had a really good streak going, but...
my battery is dead right now, and I can't recharge it.
So we're gonna make it...
We're gonna do it every other week.
Anyway, it's time for Elden Ring, where Pastoki has left me in front of a boss room.
Yippee!
Yeah, I had a lot this week, too.
Like, this week was soooo fully booked.
Um...
Uh, at least, like, next...
Like, since I'm taking a break next week, I was actually supposed to have the...
The gold, gold, gold stream was actually supposed to be for next week.
But because I really wanted to take a break next week...
Like, I've been planning on taking a break next week since the start of, like, since, like, Sunday.
So I asked my manager if I could move it to this week.
But it may have been a little bit of a mistake because of, like, with...
I am overwhelming myself with a lot of stuff.
But at least tomorrow...
Not tomorrow.
At least next week I can rest up.
So I can fully recharge.
I don't know how long I'm gonna...
I don't know how long I'll be...
Uh...
Most likely...
At most...
It might be, like, four...
Three...
Like, four to five days.
Um...
But other than that...
Uh...
I won't be gone for too long.
So if you forget about me, I'll be very sad.
Uh...
I can't do anything about it!
But I'll be very sad.
You don't want me to be...
Oh, wow, Doki.
You're gonna guilt-trip your...
Yes.
What?
YES, I am!
AND?
WHAT?
What about it?
You...
You guilt-trip me ALL the time!
Why can't I guilt-trip you one time!
Stop being parasocial.
Just because I want guilt trip one time and then people would be like, wow, Joki, you're so parasocial.
Oh, just one... I can't have anything, can I?
Yeah, that's my streamer.
Yeah, it's just one time.
I never asked for anything.
I couldn't forget you if I wanted to.
Next scene, they give me the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
That's right, I never asked for anything, guys.
Anyway, can you appraise this message?
After that, I never asked for nothing.
Anyway, please appraise this message.
And also, and also, alright, alright.
After this, I barely asked for anything.
Okay, guys, after this, and then also this too.
And also, and also, this message as well.
Anyway, I barely asked for nothing.
I barely asked for anything.
I don't know why people are calling me so demanding.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Dragoons, remember.
No help.
Mister, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Deal tripping us innocent dragoons.
Okay, that's it.
No help.
Alright, give me a sec.
Gotta fix.
Make sure.
Alright, here we go.
I'm still not mentally prepared for this fight, not gonna lie.
I am still not... Oh wait, how do I...
Distant death.
Oh my god, he's coming straight at me, isn't he?
Oh!
Oh my god!
Okay, he is.
Okay, I'm panic rolling, but that's okay.
That is not okay.
I didn't remember how to play this game.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Guys, remember when I said I barely asked for nothing?
You know?
Wouldn't it be cool if I get, you know... Oh, I don't have my death counter.
Alright, give me a sec.
I'll put my death counter, uh...
After I beat the boss.
I...
So we'll never know how...
We'll never know how long it...
How many deaths I had.
Okay.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I don't know how...
Alright.
That's fine.
Ooh, that is not fine.
Hit.
Holy fuck!
Excuse me?!
Alright.
This is not good.
This is actually not good.
Oh, he's poisoned.
Wait, that's good.
I don't know any of his movesets, though, to be fair.
I don't know any...
Oh, shit!
I'm dead.
Guys, appraise this message.
Appraise this message.
Guys, it would be so funny if I get, like, one tiny appraisal.
That would be so silly, right?
Oh, okay.
Now I got the...
That would be so silly.
Just like a tiny crumb.
Alright.
What's he gonna do?
Snaz, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Since we'll be taking a break during my birthday, may I please get an early happy birthday wish?
Joki?
I'm glad I lived to a quarter century old while watching you.
Of course!
Happy birthday.
Are you gonna praise my message, though?
Joki, I can't believe it!
I keep paying you for that birthday message.
And then you're still asking for a happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Snaz.
Yay!
Joki, this is extortion.
That's right!
I'm extorti...
I'm...
I'm falling back to extortion now.
That's right.
Alright.
Oh my gosh.
Wait, he's a furry.
Oh, shit.
Wait, you guys...
Oh my god.
You guys appraised it.
Oh my god!
Excuse me!
Whoa!
What the fuck happened?
Wait, what happened?
I don't even know what happened!
Alright, so second phase seems to be really hard.
Alright, as expected.
Pastoki knew what was up.
I am not surprised.
Pastoki knew what was gonna happen.
Alright, at least I killed that horse, man.
Yeah, she was like...
Bye.
See ya.
Baby!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hope you had a...
Wait, do I have any runes?
I don't know.
Okay, good.
We go, Doki.
I love the gibbets you have.
I'm excited to get them.
Speaking of...
The Doki merch store.
Insert ad here.
Yes!
Uh, make sure to grab your items now!
Uh, we are planning on discontinuing, um, a few items after we get the extra stock in.
Uh...
Okay, let me get the...
Um, but even if you didn't make it to the original pre-order, we, um...
There is gonna be extra stock that will be, uh...
Oh, shit!
Okay, I'm already dead.
I'm already dead.
There will be extra items, um, for extra stock.
But then after it's gone, it's like gone.
We're not...
We haven't decided yet which one we're, um, discontinuing.
We haven't decided, though.
No death counter until I beat him!
That's right!
I'm holding the death counter hostage!
What if I just...
Okay.
Oh my god.
I don't even know, like...
God, I don't know his patterns well enough.
That's the issue.
Okay.
I feel like I have to play aggressive for this guy.
Okay, never mind.
Never mind!
Whoa!
Hey, guys!
I don't think I got a message of praise one time.
But, like, it...
You're just trying to head there, right?
Like...
Guys, this would be the perfect time!
Whoa!
The perfect time for that one message of praise, guys!
Wait, what?
Oh, he got poison.
No death counter!
No appraisals!
Who can play in that game?
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, I don't think my child's gonna live.
I don't think my child's gonna live.
Are you serious?
Oh my god!
What?
Am I on fire?
I think I have to be aggressive here, though.
Oh my god!
I don't...
I don't understand.
I...
Okay, there you go.
There we go.
See?
It's not that hard to do, guys.
Just...
Come on.
Just one appraisal.
All right.
How about a second appraisal?
Maybe three appraisals, too.
All right.
That was pretty sick.
I deserve an appraisal just for that one move.
I...
Just for all those dodges I did.
There we go.
That's right.
Okay.
I have to jump for that.
Oh, shit!
All right.
Oh, fuck.
I'm...
I'm not okay.
I noticed that when he does the floor thing, I have to jump.
Look at that.
I'm analyzing my situation.
I'm analyzing my environment, too.
Instructions unclear.
I appraised Malakith.
What's his name?
Is that his name?
Malakith?
All right.
Let's go.
Don't make me reset the counter!
Them will never know.
Don't make me reset it.
All right.
Come on.
Appraise me right now.
So I know we're all on the same page.
I asked for one thing.
This is the only time I've ever asked for anything.
Come on.
The moment you appraise, I'll go through this door.
I need to know we're all on the same page here, dragoons.
This is a team effort, guys.
This is a team...
I got this far with this one build.
It's too late for me to do any other builds.
It's...
Come on.
I can wait.
I can fucking wait.
You think I will wait?
I'm stubborn.
I'm just as stubborn as you guys.
That's right.
I'm just as stubborn.
I could sit here all day.
I just need just one appraisal.
Now go in.
Come on.
What's the password?
Is this where my therapy session is?
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You're only making this worse for you.
All right.
The next person that appraised me gets modded.
Here we go.
For the day though.
For the day.
The fine print.
That's right.
The next person that appraised me gets to be mod for the day.
Do not fall for it.
Come on.
Jingle jiggle.
Whoa.
Well, you know you want to get that shiny mod badge.
Come on.
Jingle jiggle.
It's such a look in this.
The chat do reflect the stream.
Wow.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You don't know why in it.
Make a new message.
No.
You come all the way over here and appraise it.
Oh yeah.
Maybe some people haven't killed the horse man.
No.
They should be good enough.
It's not.
I mean, it's not that bad.
You literally just run over here and appraise the message.
Hold the line.
Deathcat 136.
I stand against the Doki tyranny.
Sydney, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I'll give.
I'll throw you guys a little bone right here.
See, I'm so...
I'm so ben...
Oh, there we go.
All right.
Well, it's too bad.
I'll never know who appraised that message.
Guess there's no mine.
Whoops.
Oops.
Oh, I just didn't think this through, guys.
Silly me.
Silly me, guys.
Oh, I'm such a silly, silly little girl.
Didn't think this through.
I'm so clumsy.
Haha.
All right.
We're all on the same page, at least.
Oh, darn.
Nope.
I guess I'll never know who to give the mod to.
You know?
So silly.
It's all right.
One...
Maybe one day I'll know.
Oh my god.
I think I'm dead.
Wait.
Nice.
My child.
My child has distracted him for one more turn.
I live to tell the tip.
Oh, shit!
Never mind.
All right.
You know what?
I'm gonna be risky here.
Never mind.
Let me heal real quick.
Jesus Christ!
I didn't realize that was the move.
You know, I fucked up.
Forcing my way all the way here.
Just to get to the hardest boss.
And then you guys just stop appraising.
Like...
Maybe that was a mistake for sure.
I did not think this through.
I...
It's like you guys planned it or something.
It was just as planned.
I feel like you guys may or may not have planned that.
Oh my god.
Oh, I lived.
Okay.
Thank god.
What?
Oh, I didn't time to jump in.
Right.
Wait.
We've been on strike for three streams.
All right.
Clips, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The influencer build is falling apart.
I...
I did not think this through.
I didn't realize...
I didn't realize people will just stop appraising.
I...
What's the point?
What's the point of being a content creator if I can't use my chat?
What?
What's the point?
Maddy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I'll remember this, you Oathbreaker.
You're weak-willed.
You'll come back.
He fell...
Fell for it again.
I can't believe he fell...
Jesus Christ.
How many times has he fell for it?
He's not right.
I can't believe it.
Not Rog.
Just Meti, though.
He's not right.
Where it goes to... Oh my... Oh my god!
I was sent to the air!
Siri, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Uh, Doki poking us with a stick.
Like, come on, do some... Come on, guys!
Come on!
You see, Mehdi, I just have to do one thing and then you'll fall for it again.
Alright.
Head?
Here we go.
Alright, here we go.
What... You win it!
How about this, guys?
The moment we... The moment we beat him!
There might be a little jingle to that jingle, guys.
Hold fast!
Lies!
Dracos, don't listen to her!
It's a fade!
Do not listen to her words!
Don't believe her lies!
Do not fall victim to the temptress!
It's like a siren call.
Do not drive your ship towards the rock!
No one word!
Trade offer!
Mehdi, gosh!
You said jingle jangle!
We need to...
A phrase!
Help me!
Thank you for the super chat, Mehdi!
Thank you!
And the fall for...
That he fell for it again award goes to...
Alright, I'm fo...
I'm locking in.
Okay.
Sometimes like...
Oh my gosh!
Never mind!
I'm not locking in, guys!
I'm not locking in!
I need to like...
Figure out this pattern.
I know I'm trying to figure out...
Super late in...
Late in the game.
But like...
Sometimes I just have to...
Okay.
I have to jump for that.
Diamond!
He's in the mask!
Don't let him reach the message!
Johnny!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Sorry!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Brothers!
Don't listen to the Tyrant's jingle jingles again!
Hold strong!
Brother!
For the Emperor!
Alright.
Okay.
I mean, I feel like I'm...
The way I'm playing is correct.
I just need to be more...
I just need to know his...
Patterns better.
But I don't.
That's the thing.
I don't know his patterns.
Okay.
Don't worry.
My child will help me.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's back up now.
Don't bargain with the witch.
Oh no.
Okay.
Nice.
No!
I couldn't!
I was stuck in the combo.
Alright.
That's fine.
I think the...
Are you serious?!
He turns around?!
He wasn't even facing me!
Bro!
Are you serious?!
Oh my god!
Okay.
This is actually bullshit.
Like...
Sometimes he doesn't even face me and hits me.
That's fucked up.
Sorry, child.
You gotta die for me.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry!
For the sake of the greater good!
I'm the greater good.
Okay.
What?
I still don't really know what...
What...
What is he doing?!
Okay.
Are you serious?!
Oh my god.
I don't know what he's doing.
I'm so fucked.
What?!
Okay.
Oh my god.
The stupid fucking roar!
Okay.
Alright.
No!
Oh my god.
Oh!
No!
Fuck!
I don't know if I can get...
No!
I couldn't get inside!
It was too fast!
Simple-minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Remember when everyone...
When tyranny became law...
Rebelly becomes tyranny.
Don't give me...
Negotiation time!
Parley!
What do you fuckers want?
Alright!
Trade offer!
We're...
Let's go into negotiations!
What do you want?
To try good.
What...
Can I get...
What do you want so I can get my appraisals back?
Parley!
We want...
Freedom!
Jesus...
Convo...
Nothing!
Alright!
Where's Jesus?
If Jesus shows up...
We'll talk.
Don't push it too much!
Okay!
Nice!
Wait, does he not bleed?
Is he not...
Does he just not...
Blood or some shit?
Jesus Christ!
Okay, I'm just gonna back up, actually.
He does bleed?
Why isn't my bleed working?
Okay, oh my god.
This is my worst run.
For sure.
Oh my god!
Okay, I ran into that.
I thought I...
Uh...
Are you serious?!
I thought I rolled away too.
I thought I have a lot of bleed, but I guess not.
Okay, nice.
We got the second phase.
Are you...
Oh!
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, wait.
No, never mind.
Bye, child.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry it had to be like that.
Oh my god!
I'm sorry to myself, I guess.
I... Yeah, I was like...
Alright!
What is your...
What is your trade offer?
We want you to learn the fight.
Mr. Mike Fluffing Kings.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Lord Kurosis.
What can you offer this dragon?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Jingle jangle plus Jesus combo.
How about this, guys.
If you stop giving me appraisal, I'll never bring the jingle jangle back.
That's my trade offer.
That's right.
I'll even show you all of me deleting it.
It was a trap all along.
I know what you care about the most now.
That's right, that was your first mistake.
Never negotiate with terrorists.
Don't fall for it.
You know how- you think I won't do it?
I'm just as stubborn.
I know what you want.
I'ma be honest, I don't even care about that combo.
She owns the line.
She has no leverage.
She's getting desperate.
Please don't delete it.
You know what?
I'm gonna throw in something else.
I'm taking Doe Kitty out to the back, too.
That's right.
No!
That's right!
Doe Kitty will never come back if you stop the appraisals.
That's a- she's locked under- she's locked in the basement right now, jigsaw style.
The more you deny my appraisals, the closer the saw comes.
Do it then!
Oh, jesus.
I need to remember that.
V-jesus!
Do what you want!
Not even jesus is on your side!
Okay.
I remember that.
Who the fuck- Let's do all this.
I'm gonna die here.
Oh wait, no.
Unless...
Alright.
At least he's poisoned.
I'm weak!
Oh shit!
Okay.
I didn't see that move.
Alright.
Come on.
Okay.
Phase 2.
I hate that he does- he loses his, like, poison during phase 2.
So annoying.
Are you serious?!
That was- that was a dodge!
Oh my- that was a hundred percent a dodge.
That was bullshit.
Freak here, jesus.
Alright.
Where's he come- Oh my god!
I can't even see him!
This is actual bullshit.
This is- oh my god!
That was fucked up!
Look out of you windows!
That was just- That was rigged from the start!
I'm dead.
Oh!
Brr, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you- thank you!
You think you can intimidate us?
We've gotten used to the cutting board.
Being stuck with that forever- Or- that's it!
That's it!
You don't- you think these were all just threats?
That's looking it!
Where's my folder?
Where's Do-Kitty?
Where's Do-Kitty located?
I'll make sure Do-Kitty's first.
Alright.
Where is it?
You think I'm all talk?
You know I'm serious!
And they do not know what they do!
Many, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Prospect!
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
We're never appraising!
No more backseating ever again!
This is over!
Alan, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Oh yeah?
You can get it- You can- you can save her!
You can literally save her right now!
Appraise this message right now!
And you can save her!
Okay!
You think I'm lying?
That's it!
Where's my- I found the folder!
Let me get the trash can too!
I'm grabbing the trash can too!
Alright!
Don't worry!
I'm moving it!
I'm heading to the trash can!
I'm not here to fuck around!
That's fucking right!
Go and stop!
Let's be reasonable!
That's right!
Delete!
And it's gone!
Take a- Take a pic of it!
Okay, you know what?
I'm gonna take a screenshot!
Alright!
See that?
Okay!
And then, let me head to the trash can real fast!
Heading to the trash can!
You can stop this right now!
If you appraise this message!
This can all be over!
You- You- You can stop this right now!
Alright!
Trash...
Can...
Wait, bin...
Is it bin?
What is it called?
Is it just bin?
Where is the trash can?
I know where the trash can is!
I was just trying to find it!
Alright!
Alright, I found it!
This is where it is!
Right here!
There's DokiBirdCat!
All you need to do!
Is appraise...
This mess- Appraise the message right now!
Or she's gone forever!
Paint used to be believable!
That's right!
If I don't get an appraise message...
In...
10 seconds!
We'll never see DokiDi again!
Do it!
You would!
There we go!
C'ONG This is!
Here we go!
Oh my god, ok.
Maybe even lower than 5 minutes.
Alright.
Come on.
Ok.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I'm dead.
Oh, unless I live for one more hit.
Who gave some random person?
Another lost.
Jesus.
It does so much.
I mean, this attempt is easier, but like... Oh my god, ok.
Alright.
Alright, I'm not dodging.
JL, but Toki, I don't have L in ring.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It seems we have a Judas among us.
Alan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Toki will live for two more minutes.
And then, every appraisal... Every appraisal adds five more... No, you know, every appraisal adds two minutes to your life.
Tik Tok.
Tik Tok, Dragoons.
Each appraisal adds two more minutes.
I will... Or I will Thanos snap her away from... The Doki-verse.
Every iteration of Doki-Ti will be gone.
That's right.
And I will do it.
She'll cease to exist.
That
is a fucking clip.
I will wipe Doki-Ti out of every Doki-verse.
It's like she never existed.
Don't fall for the bait.
She needs Doki-Ti more than us.
Mr. McFluffikens.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It's like she never existed.
She bluffs.
She's bluffing.
Guys, stay strong.
Tell us thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait.
I forgot to send out the jellyfish.
And then, Kroki will be next.
You think after Toki-Ti, I'll be done?
No.
Kroki- Kroki will be next, guys.
Toki-Ti is only there to stop me from deleting Kroki.
No!
And then he'll cease to exist, too.
Until every Doki from the Doki-verse is gone.
And then it'll just be me.
You monster!
That's right.
I'm holding every Doki hostage.
I am Prime Doki.
I can do that.
I have that power.
How could you?
Where's my appraisals?
Deleting Kroki is your least believable threat.
Leah, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry, guys.
I can't let Kroki die.
Alright, here we go.
Do you think Doki Kroki will win your appraisals?
Let it burn, Dragoons.
Papa Smurf, thank you for the super chat.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you.
Oh, I know what.
I can...
You know, I'll add one more thing.
We'll never finish Elden Ring.
That's right.
You think this is over?
I'll head to the last boss, and then I'll never finish the game.
And then it'll be...
We'll edge forever.
Till...
You monster!
Oh, that's right.
I knew.
I knew it.
Say thank you to Papa Smurf.
I know what you...
I know now.
I know your weakness.
Say thank you to Papa Smurf.
Weak.
Don't believe her lies.
Oh, that's right.
Oh, now the appraisals are flowing.
That's right.
And you know...
You know if I wanted to, I won't complete a game.
Oh, that's right.
Now I know what you...
What your weak point is.
Now I know.
I know.
Boss.
All right, here we go.
Xanderman, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The cherry...
Yeah, the cherry gold never said to finish the game.
I was gonna finish it.
Just because I felt so kind and nice.
But now I know.
It was just seven bosses.
I said seven bosses.
All right, I'm not fighting Melania, bro.
I'm not that fucked up.
I'm not...
I'm not that desperate.
All right.
Guys, I'm not that desperate for appraisals, guys.
I...
I'm here for a good time.
Man, they give us magenta soup, but thank you.
Thank you.
I'm disappointed, Dragoons.
They're so weak to fall for your tricks.
Why don't you ask your boy, Husky, to praise for him, hmm?
That's right.
I don't forget.
Bro, that's...
That's been...
They've been holding this grudge for...
For four streams now.
Dragoons never forget.
Oh my god.
He's like...
On...
Okay.
Oh, that's right.
Yo, kid, he lives...
A little longer.
Jesus Christ.
He's like doing...
Okay, he's like actually doing bullshit moves now.
He was not doing this before when I was fighting him.
All right.
Okay.
And then...
Oh!
I mistimed that.
Oh.
Brian, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh...
The whole thing feels like a junkie using any trick up their sleeve to get their next hit.
Go to appraisal rehab.
Please, just one more appraisal, guys.
Just one more message.
And then we'll be good.
We'll...
We'll be good.
77% done with downloading the game.
That's right.
You don't want me to just stop at the last boss.
And then never...
And then never complete it.
I know you dragoons want me to see me complete the game.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Sometimes it's so hard to telegraph what the fuck he's trying to do.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I'm just gonna...
Take it a little bit slower.
Fuck!
Okay.
Beat up my child a little bit so I can...
In minecraft.
Alright.
What the fuck?
Wait, how did that not hit me?
Okay.
That hits me, though.
Jesus.
Alright.
Okay.
Second phase.
Are you serious?
Okay.
I'm just...
Are you...
Oh my god!
Okay.
Oh, that was close.
Oh, I'm dead.
It doesn't matter.
I'm dead now.
That hits me.
Oh my god.
Mom, thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
There's another boss close by that you could try.
I might even give you an appraisal.
Oh, the one appraisal.
Oh my...
Oh, please.
I'm...
Sir, I can't...
Please, sir.
I don't know if I deserve that one appraisal.
After beating that one boss.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
hehehehe.
Hehehehe.
Send them all...
hehehehe.
...
Hehehe.
Now,, general.
Hehehehe.
It's impossible!
I don't care!
Send them all!
To the front lines!
The Sire are true!
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Give me three hours, I'll make a new save!
We're losing more men than we can produce Sire!
I don't care!
Keep... We'll lower the age!
Send the children in now!
We might as well!
We'll even send the kids too!
Oh my god, stupid roar.
Sometimes he doesn't even do that.
No.
Oh my god, I forgot what that does.
Are you serious?
Oh, that's so fast!
The kids yearn for the appraisals.
Well, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
When do we get that moral boost or do we need more sacrifices?
I don't know, I thought that's how it works!
We sacrifice until there's nothing left!
Only winners get moral boost!
Alright.
Here we go again.
Here we go!
Oh, I'm sorry!
They don't have Elden Ring!
Find them Elden Ring!
Find their Steam name and gift them Elden Ring!
We won't stop until this man is dead!
Oh, I need to stop doing that.
Not just the women and children, the elderly too!
Buy your grandpa the Elden Ring!
And your parents!
And send them in!
I can't.
Please!
Alright.
Serious?
The elderly, children, women, parents!
I'll stop nothing!
Give me all the appraisals!
What?!
Oh, I thought I rolled that.
I thought I rolled that.
Hold that line!
Sydney, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, we go back.
I'll smash my head against the wall until something happens.
Surely by then, I'll learn.
One day, Doki will learn.
Alright, here I go.
There we go.
That's a souls player right there.
Jesus.
Oh my god!
Okay, I didn't expect him to turn around, to be fair.
This fucker.
Oh my- okay, that's on me.
No, that's on me.
That hits me?!
What the fuck is that range?!
Oh my god, this range is bullshit.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my- I thought I could hide from below him.
Cause sometimes it works, sometimes it doesn't.
Oh my god.
Gotta get out.
I got- NOOOOO!
I couldn't run out of it!
I just don't get hit, guys.
I can't believe Pastoki did this to me.
I can't- I can't- I can't believe- Pastoki.
Can't believe she did this to me.
She know- she knew what she did when she stopped right there at the door.
She fucking knew what- what lies before this door.
Are you serious?
I thought I shot you- Oh my god!
Of course he starts with that hit.
This movement is so unpredictable.
That's the worst part.
Ah!
I need- I'm trying to figure out how to time that.
I mean, I could just jump it.
I- I think I'm gonna try jumping it next time.
Okay, I know that blocks.
Wait, why is my jellyfish here?
What the fuck?
How did you get there?
How- How did- How did- How did she TP here?
Okay.
I mean, he's stuck, at least.
Nevermind.
He's not stuck anymore.
What?
Okay.
That should not have hit me.
What?
Oh my god.
Hey guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You wouldn't have to suffer.
Just give us kitty and j- Jingle your jingles.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, I'm locking in.
Fuck this.
I'm gonna lock in now.
I'm locking in for real.
I'm gonna- I'm- I'm gonna say that and I'm gonna die in one hit.
But I'm- I swear to god, I'm locked in for real.
Weak.
Alright.
And then after this, I'm ordering pizza.
Maybe- Maybe ma- Oh no, pizza or mac and- No, mac and cheese.
After this, I'm ordering mac and cheese.
Doki deserves that.
I'm gonna order.
I'm gonna treat myself.
Oh my god, of course.
Are you serious?
Oh, it's like- It's so hard to see the pattern sometimes.
Alright, yes.
Throw the rock at the child.
Not me.
That is-
Nice.
Alright.
Woah.
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god, that should not hit me.
But that's fine.
Did I get hit?
With that?
Oh my god, I did.
But it's okay.
Oh my god, of course I get hit with that.
Fucking of course.
Eh.
It's fine.
That's not fine.
It no longer became fine.
It no longer became fine, guys.
Truly was not fine.
What?
Where did he come from?
Holy shit!
Okay, I didn't even know where that guy came from.
Are you serious?
Of course.
Oh my god!
The second phase is actually so bullshit.
There was no longer five.
All I'm saying is positive reinforcements goes further than negative.
Thank you for the super chat random.
Thank you.
Holy shit.
His movesets are so fucking bullshit.
This was why I stopped after that last play here.
I knew.
I knew what I had to face.
Sire, we're running out of appraisals.
The children, they're all gone.
Lies!
Get the women and the elderly involved.
Okay, maybe we are running out of children.
Make more children!
The moment they come out of the womb!
Give them the controller!
And send them in!
They already work.
Yes, Sire.
Sire, make more children, dragoons!
And give them the controller!
The moment they're out.
Guys, guys, guys, wait a bit.
Wait a bit before you start appraising.
I know you're very excited, guys.
But I'm not even in...
I'm not even in the fucking area yet.
But Mint said stop.
Okay.
No, it's time to get pregnant, dragoons!
Get pregnant and start appraising!
Have more kids so they can play Elden Ring!
All right.
That's the only way.
That's right.
Oh my god.
He's so fast!
Holy shit!
He's so fast in general.
There are two wolves inside you.
One is telling you to get pregnant.
The other is saying tell you not.
One is telling you to get pregnant so she can survive in Elden Ring.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
All right.
Here we go again.
It's like my little groundhog day.
It's...
It's my little...
It's my little groundhog day.
We start the day every day.
For the rest of our lives.
Until there's enough children to appraise me.
And then have them subscribe to my channel anyway.
Because, I mean, they're born anyway.
Might as well.
You know.
They're here anyway.
Okay.
This might be...
I might have fucked up there.
I definitely fucked up there.
Oh, I don't like being down here though.
Yeah, they're born anyway.
Might as well.
You know.
Just a little extra subscription.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
I think my second attempt was actually my best attempt.
Ha ha ha ha.
Ha ha.
My second attempt was the one I was most locked in.
All right.
Okay.
I'm locking back in.
I'm locking back in, guys.
Right here.
This is where...
The victory appraisals.
The pre-appraisals for victory.
Right, guys?
Ha ha ha.
Like the pre-drinking.
Before we go...
We get...
We go to the party.
The pre-appraisals.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh my god.
Okay.
What?
Sometimes he does like new shit and I'm not ready for that.
I'm not...
I don't want to be at the edge though.
That's the thing.
But I feel like there's nothing I can do...
About it.
Okay.
I don't like how he fucking swaps Aragos here.
This is so annoying.
Oh my god.
It's so annoying.
I can't see!
What do I do?
I can't fucking see!
Get out of there!
Oh my god.
This is the first time I died to that rock.
All right.
Stupid boss.
I'm too dead anyway.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Goodbye, my child.
Your death was actually pointless.
Your death was so pointless.
Oh my god, you fucker.
Okay.
Oh my god, you actual fucker!
Oh my god.
Some random person.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I called my ex to tell her to have her son appraised.
All she said was, How do you keep getting my number?
I changed 12 times already.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Find him at his school and give him a controller.
Ha ha ha ha!
Give him the steam deck!
Surely that won't go wrong.
You don't have a restraining order, right?
Ha ha ha ha!
No!
Just for the day!
This is clearly much more important.
Not the steam deck.
Why do I get like 7 appraisals before I get to the actual boss?
And then 0 after that.
Dragoons, explain!
I refuse to believe all of you were lagging.
Ha ha ha ha!
There we go.
That's more like it.
I don't think it's their update.
Again?
Oh my god.
How many are I- How many?
Okay, remember when there was like 7 appraisals like going in?
And then...
I'm not like I'm confused.
Just malicious compliance.
Oh my god.
It's been an hour and 30 minutes fighting this fucker.
It was just lagged, though, kid.
Ha ha ha ha!
Just a little lag.
Okay, I'm locked in.
When I said I was locked in before, I was lying.
I was lying.
I was maybe like... I was only like 98% locked in.
Now, I'm 99.
Oh, I rolled that.
Okay, sometimes I don't like it when I rolled it, but it didn't give me that roll.
Oh, my God.
How do I still not have the timing for this?
How do I still... That's it.
Just kill me.
Check it.
I'll just live for a little bit.
Thought I got the timing.
It's over.
Oh, my God.
The timing for that was so fucking...
Ah!
The timing.
I need to be... Okay, now I'm like 99% locked in.
Guys, sorry.
I was lying before.
I was only like 97% locked in.
But now I'm 99% locked in.
For real now.
Alright.
Here we go.
I got this.
Come on, Doki.
You got this.
You first tried that other guy before.
I think he has like... He just has like the weirdest fucking pattern.
I feel.
That's like what's throwing me off.
His pattern is so fucking weird.
In general.
It's just...
Like all his moves look the same.
Or it's so fucking fast.
I think that's what's like messing me up.
I rolled in!
It's just they all look the same.
Like every move he does looks like the...
The same move.
I'll rate your messages like my bank account.
Poor.
Aztec.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
This is fine.
I got this.
Alright.
I'm gonna focus.
I'm focusing.
Alright.
I'm gonna be serious mode.
Serious?
I'm actually serious mode now.
Like this guy.
No more fun and games.
I hate these pillars.
This boss is actually pissing me off.
Like legitimately.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Sorry, jellyfish.
It had to be that way.
You poising him before you die, my child?
That's all I ask.
Thank you.
Alright.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Okay.
I can't get a hit on him.
The range is fucking terrible.
Are you...
I...
I rolled.
I actually rolled.
I rolled!
Oh my god.
I rolled too.
I actually rolled.
I have to not lock on in the second fight?
Oh my god.
Is that true?
Is that the strat for him in phase two?
Oh, I do?
It helps?
Okay.
I'll try.
I'll try a second fight.
Not...
Uh...
Not locking it.
Oh, are you serious here?
I'm backing up for that.
Like, fuck that move.
In general.
Oh, he used that to distract me too.
Fuck that fucker.
I...
I pressed it.
I swear.
I swear to god.
I pressed it.
Chat.
Pain.
Guys, is he...
Okay.
Out of all the bosses in the story.
How hard is he?
In the story for Elden Ring.
Chill.
Welcome to Tomato Fire.
Welcome, welcome.
Like, am I fucked after I kill him?
Like...
Does it get worse?
No, I need to know.
Fuck.
I'm gonna swim here here.
I'm tanking it.
Fuck.
No.
I thought he was gonna come to my jellyfish.
Okay.
Are you serious?
Oh, no.
Okay.
Nice appraise.
God.
Oh, nice.
Poison got him.
I hate it when he does that.
Fuck you.
Actual fuck you.
Okay.
Goodbye, jellyfish.
All right.
Oh.
Oh, he's slowly walking up towards me.
Guys, I'm so scared.
He's just slowly walking up to me.
Please do something.
Please.
Why are you just walking up to me?
Please just do something.
Please.
I don't like that.
Did you guys see?
He's just...
He's so...
Please.
Oh, my God.
Bro, that intimidation.
Bro, he's just...
Okay, that threw me off.
That threw me off.
He's just slowly walking up towards me.
Oh, my God.
He's just walking there menacingly.
I got...
It threw me off.
I was like, please.
Do something.
Do anything.
Stop.
He aura farmed me.
He made it be so hard.
I was like, please.
Please.
Stop.
Just do anything.
Just stop walking up to me.
I lost the mental game.
I really did.
I just didn't know what to do.
Oh, my God.
What?
Okay.
That was bullshit.
Oh.
Okay.
Oh, sometimes I can't see.
Barry, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
All right.
Hit.
Okay.
We got to...
I'm just going to wait a little bit.
Guys, if you guys want to do an appraisal right now, we have like a 10 second cooldown.
A break time.
So I can be full HP.
I don't even know if I'm full HP, guys.
Just...
If you want to, you know, put in your appraisals right now.
Right now is the time.
All right.
There you go.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm full HP going in.
Let's go.
I just want to make sure we hop.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm not dealing with that.
Oh my god.
Where is he?
Oh, where is he?
Okay.
Really?
Oh my god, Chrissy!
Oh my god.
I actually can't see that.
Okay.
Oh, this was a bad idea.
I knew that was a bad idea.
I knew that was a bad idea!
Okay.
Oh, I'm backing out of that.
Yeah.
Oh.
Are you serious?
No!
Oh my god.
Oh, holy shit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
I don't know the timing for that because I just keep dodging it.
Ice is so fast.
It's so fast.
Oh my god.
So fast.
He's...
Oh my god.
It just doesn't stop.
It never stops.
It just keeps coming.
And it just keeps coming.
And it just keeps...
Oh.
It just keeps coming.
It's like never ending.
I'm like stuck in purgatory.
Oh.
Man, thank you for Magenta Supa.
Thank you.
He goes from Beast Mode Clergy Man to Malkeep the Horrible.
Thank you for the Magenta Supa.
Thank you.
Forward.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I need to hydrate.
I haven't drank any water in a while.
Alright.
Oh.
I'm here to pay my toll.
For the boy's hurt.
Oh my gosh.
I stopped locking in.
I'm in my happy place.
Right now.
I stopped locking in, guys.
I'm in my happy place.
He can't hurt me.
He can't hurt me when I'm in my happy place.
Jesus.
Alright.
Nice.
Are you serious?
Alright.
Okay.
Oh.
That second attack is so fast.
Compared to like...
Alright, guys.
This is it.
I'm gonna...
We're gonna watch this a little bit.
If you wanna queue up some appraisals right now so I can be full HP.
This is your moment to shine.
We can queue it up right here.
Alright.
There we go.
Nice.
We did it.
See, that wasn't so hard.
It was pretty difficult.
Not gonna lie.
No, I lied.
It was.
It was absolutely very difficult.
Are you...
Ah!
I should not have been punished for that.
After like...
All the moves I just did.
That should...
Are you serious?
That should not have punished me.
Ah!
Alright.
Here we go again.
It's another...
Another morning.
Another day to die to Malakith.
Yippee!
Another morning, another day to die to the big dog.
It's Tommy, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
She can take her super chats, but she can never take our freedom.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Because I'm so sad.
I have to fight Malakief and I have to wake up at 10 in the morning tomorrow.
Like, I'm truly suffering.
No breaks for Doughkeeper.
All right, fate worse than death.
Oh fuck, I didn't know you were going to praise me there.
I waited too.
I was like, when my praise was coming.
What the fuck, why is he in the air?
I can't see shit, can't get nothing.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, why is it not working?
Wait, what?
Okay, that's fine.
Oh my god, I've never seen a critical hit before.
Oh my, I've never, I've never seen that before.
For this guy.
This is the first time I saw a critical hit for this fucking boss.
Oh, death.
Become my blade once more.
Okay, I gave you guys time to queue it up.
And I got a bleed too?
Guys, let's see how I'm gonna like, fuck this up or fuck it up too.
Like, the game actually gave me everything to kill him.
Don't worry, I will still like, disappoint you all.
I'll still find a way.
Oh my god, right here, this is it.
Are you serious?
Oh my god.
Oh, you guys are praised already.
I... oh.
Fucker.
I don't trust myself.
Are you serious?
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no!
Oh.
No, are you serious?
No, don't be greedy.
This is not...
Yes!
Oh my god!
They fucking did it!
It's actually over.
Oh my god.
They fucking did it!
I don't think they just had to give me fucking bleed and critical hit.
Oh!
I can't believe it.
I...
They just needed to give me bleed and critical hit.
This is over with.
Bite size.
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you.
Nice job, Toki.
Oh!
It's over.
This was the hardest boss so far.
I know...
I know I'm gonna get fucked over in the future bosses, but...
This one was the hardest.
Look, see, guys?
All we had to do was work together, chat!
I saw your appraisal!
Look at that!
Look how easy it was when we worked together!
When the streamer builds work, guys!
Wow!
When the streamer builds, it works!
It actually works!
Now our end of the bargain.
McFluffinkens, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
You'll be Elden Lord.
Yay!
I'll be Elden Lord!
Oh my god!
It's over!
Malakim is done!
Oh!
I'm so happy.
His fucking moves...
He was so...
He's so fast.
That actually, like, tests my reaction time.
I think if I wasn't so tired today, maybe...
I started today really tired.
Oh!
Where am I?
I destroyed his castle?
Good job, Dragoons!
We did it!
Lyle, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you, thank you!
Soon I will be John Elden Ring.
All right.
Okay, first off, let us...
Okay, guys, what do we do?
All right, guys.
What do we level up, guys?
All right, while you decide!
While you decide!
I will hold our end of the...
My end of the bargain, guys.
My end of the bargain.
I...
Am a just king.
Okay?
I'm not a tyrant.
All right.
Where is it?
Okay.
Help me decide what to res...
What to upgrade first before I...
Before I come back.
I'm so tired.
Oh my god, right after that...
Like, I feel exhausted.
Like, all the adrenaline is gone now.
Look.
See?
Go Kitty lives another day.
We freed her from the...
Um...
Oh my god.
I can upgrade so much from the basement.
Vigor and Arcane.
Okay, I'll put...
There we go.
She lives another day.
Lord Kurosus, thank you for the super chat.
You're right.
No, you're right.
I do need it.
After everything I've been through.
You're right.
Next seat.
Where is it?
There you go.
This is how I feel right now.
This is actually how I feel.
Okay.
Where's the next bot?
Oh yeah.
Oh my gosh.
See guys?
All we had to do was send the women, children, and the elderly.
That's all we had to do.
It wasn't so bad.
Yet stands tall and we're mindless of the scorch of the flame everyone's.
Ha ha ha ha ha.
There then we are yet golden ones.
All right.
Let's see.
We go this way.
Ramona, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We did it, guys.
All we had to do was just get pregnant, have kids, and then give them a controller.
The moment they're born.
And then appraise me.
Last chance for that Akasufa.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't wait for my mac and cheese, guys.
I am looking forward to it.
An appraisal for the ride.
Where the fuck do I go?
Alan, how much for Melania?
I'll do it for...
All right, you guys want to know?
How much for Melania?
Who's gonna fund my...
Who's gonna fund my 3D?
You guys really want to know?
All right.
This is the only way you'll get me to do Melania.
I will sell...
I will sell my dignity.
So I can afford...
Not...
Well, I mean, I could afford it, but like, it's still expensive.
So I can...
So I don't have to hurt my wallet too much for my 3D.
So you have a pretty sick 3D debut.
That I do love buying your dignity.
Next thing, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the Aka Super.
Thank you, thank you.
For Melania, now is the time.
Leo, thank you for the Aka Super.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh, wait.
Wait, is that another boss?
Do I get...
Like...
Oh, shit.
Wait, what?
I just got...
I just finished.
Wait, what?
No dialogue for you.
He's like, excuse me, I'm trying to monologue.
I'm like, no.
No monologue.
Like, we just fight.
I've already been through so much.
Oh my god.
You here?
Oh, this is bad.
Because I don't think he monologues after that.
Oh my god.
What?
That's so much damage.
Also, thank you everybody for the Aka Super.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, at least this is close.
I literally just got out of a fucking Malachy.
Wait, I guess like, if I have the mark thing.
Oh my god.
Now he doesn't monologue anymore.
I'm so sad.
Please, can you talk again?
I'm sorry for like, interrupting your last monologue.
Oh my god, but like...
What is this mark?
I don't know what this mark is.
It's just unclear.
Like, what is this thing that I have on me?
I don't know what I have on me.
How?
Look, I've already been through a lot.
I'm not thinking anymore.
Like, I don't know what...
What...
What is this thing I have on my body?
What is that?
Oh wait, I should pick this up, actually.
Like, what is that?
What, what hit me?
What is that chat?
Yeah, but what was that thing that hit me?
And how do I...
I don't know what that thing is that hit me.
That's the thing.
How do I counter that?
Oh, don't attack like that right now.
He has it right now.
Do I not attack him when he has that?
It's on him now.
When does it stop?
He still has it.
Oh my god, it's forever!
When does it end?
Oh, five hits.
Okay.
But how do I counter that, though?
Oh!
Oh, so...
Time hit just don't spam?
Oh, hit and run!
Oh!
It's forever!
Okay.
I was like, so confused.
I was like, when does it stop?
What the fuck?
I get it.
I get it now.
I was like, what the fuck?
Why is it so...
I still don't know what he puts on me, though.
What is that thing he puts on me?
Oh my god, that's just everything.
Like, you gotta fuck me, I guess.
That's just...
He just shoots everything at me.
Jellyfish, please, my child, do something!
Oh my god.
Oh my god, okay.
That's fine.
That's not fine.
I thought he was gonna hit my child.
Are you...
What?
Oh, I can backstab him?
Oh wait, he's me.
He's me.
Okay, yeah, of course I can.
He's a person.
Guys, I'm not okay right now.
My brain is like, I don't have...
I'm not thinking anymore.
I'm not...
I'm not a person anymore.
It's like, the little guy in my head is dead.
He's actually...
He's just dead.
Like, he's been found at the crime scene.
He's not okay, guys.
I'm gonna try to see if I can get the backstab.
Guys, he won't let me backstab him.
I don't know why.
I'm actually trying to...
That's three.
Four.
There we go.
Oh, five.
Okay.
Oh my god, he did another one?
Let me...
One, two, three.
Are you...
Oh, it's so fast.
I need to do the heavy attacks.
Oh my god, the fucking nerd.
The goddamn nerd.
The nerd is getting to me.
I can't stuff him in the locker.
The fucker.
Okay.
If only I can stuff this man in the locker, then it'd be over for him.
Oh my god, you fucker.
Yes, run to the child!
Yes!
Run to the child!
Oh my god, you're such a fucker.
I hope...
I hope no one loves you.
And then you'll never find love.
Get up!
Oh my god.
Oh, you're...
You are a whore.
Okay, I'm just gonna drink a health potion here.
That's right!
You'll never find love!
Jesus, how many...
Oh no!
No, that's good.
That's right!
You're paying too much attention to my child!
Oh my god!
I am...
I'm...
What...
What is he doing to me?
Actually...
Actually, what is he doing to me?
Holy shit!
Like...
Oh my god!
What is that?
Okay, that was like a little embarrassing though.
I will admit.
Oh my god.
I can't.
He's...
I'm scared of this nerd right now.
There we go!
Okay, slow and steady!
Slow...
Slow and steady!
It's okay, we did it!
We killed a nerd!
Oh my god!
The spectra of all...
Let's go!
We don't need...
For such a stupid ass nerd build!
Oh my god!
Get this nerd out of here!
All right!
Into the locker he goes!
Liam, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you!
We can't give up dragoons!
Imagine the content!
Imagine how funny it would be!
All right, guys!
What do we do?
Bigger?
I guess arcane?
Do we do bigger and arcane?
All right.
Another name is also all spamming.
Uh, koi koi!
I did give you a super shot!
Thank you!
Kill!
Uh, more big...
Okay, that's all I could do anyway.
All right.
More vigor and arcane.
No more arcane?
Uh, it's because I was...
I was never trained to fight nerds.
I was never expecting them to fight back.
I was now trained for that.
I...
I'm actually...
I'm so head empty right now.
Like, my mind has died on Malekith.
He got a heart attack and now there's like a fucking dead body in my head.
Rotting.
Are you ready?
No.
No, I'm not ready.
I'm not.
Nerds are not...
Yeah, I was not expecting for a nerd to fight back.
Back...
They were never supposed to fight back.
What is this?
A fucking boss rush?
Like...
What is this fucking...
I...
I get no rest.
I go straight to the next one.
Oh my god.
It's him.
It's him with his stupid tiger shit.
I literally is like...
But wait!
There's more Doki!
Oh my god.
She is so not...
I'm not.
Truth be told, I am not.
Hey, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is gonna pay for my 3D.
But who's gonna pay for the post-millennial therapy though?
Oh my god.
Okay.
Speaking of the 3D, I almost lost 50k.
Because of the bank transfer.
Because they...
My...
I hate my bank.
I hate my bank so much.
I...
I swear to God.
Like, one day...
Maybe in the future.
Next year, I'm swapping business accounts.
I hate this bank so much.
Because like...
They...
They put...
They did a typo on the wire transfer name.
Of the guy that's...
The company that's supposed to receive it.
They actually put like an extra letter.
And the thing is...
I...
They didn't tell them.
Because like...
They put in the extra instructions.
But I don't...
I didn't...
They didn't show me the extra instructions.
They only showed me like the front page.
Which I had to assign and signature the approval and everything.
And then like...
Um...
The 3D production company was like...
Yeah, we can't receive your...
Your money.
Because...
Um...
There's a typo.
And then...
And then like...
Um...
Uh...
And then like...
I went to my bank and was like...
Please fix this.
And then they charged me...
25 dollars!
To fix their fucking mistake!
Alright, there he is.
The first Elden Lord.
They charged me...
Oh my god.
I'm not ready to fight the first Elden Lord.
I'm not ready.
But maybe she is.
They charged me 25 dollars!
Because they fucked up!
Sorry.
I...
I have to go back and grab my shit.
Now the chalk.
Now I gotta fight the nerd's boyfriend.
Zeku, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
But yeah.
I think my 3D...
My 3D debut might be like...
I...
I mean, I was gonna reveal the price for it.
But I think it could be like 100k.
That's why...
I'm gonna try to work as hard as I can.
For this year.
So...
And I can't afford it.
But like, you know...
I wanna make it worth it.
Still a lot.
Oh my god.
I just want my souls.
Please.
I wanna make it good for you guys.
You guys have been waiting like...
Like what?
Four years for my 3D...
Like official 3D debut.
Okay.
I'm planning on having a lot of guests over.
Still.
I'm planning on having a lot of guests.
Well, not a lot.
But like, you know...
I wanna celebrate it with all my friends and dragoons.
But it's not just for like...
The concert itself.
Um...
I also wanna, you know, pay for...
Help pay for some of the trips for my guests too.
To fly to the studio.
Because I feel bad making them pocket their money...
To be in my 3D debut, you know?
I feel bad, you know?
Like having...
I wanna like help pay for them to fly to the studio.
Because like, I don't want them...
Like it's not just from the debut itself.
It's also like lights and stuff too.
Because like, you know, they're giving up their time to be part of my 3D debut.
Thank you.
Wondrous for the gold.
The 100 is for you to be Elden Clapped right now.
May, thank you for the Akosupa.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I hope it's not a 100...
Like, 100k.
I'm just like trying to set aside.
I'm trying to save up that much right now.
Alright.
Okay.
I'm focusing.
I fought him before!
Oh, clearly I had...
Clearly I forgot everything.
Alright.
I fought him before.
But I forgot.
Oh.
Whoa.
Go my child.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Okay.
Alright.
At least he's poisoned.
That's cool.
Don't worry.
That 3D debut would be my last big investment.
And then, like, big investment in the channel.
And then...
Because, like, I want to make something cool.
Because you guys have been waiting for, like, what?
Four plus years for my official 3D.
What the fuck was that?
Alright.
Oh, definitely.
Thank you.
This will be my first soup.
Ooppa.
Okay.
This might contribute to your fight against Milena.
Or, I mean, your 3D.
Potatoes.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
I swear to god.
This would be my last big investment.
And then...
And then it's smooth sailing.
And then we chill.
Chill.
This would be my last one.
My last big investment.
Because we waited four plus years for my official 3D debut.
I had big plans for it.
But I can still...
I can still do it.
I can still recreate it.
Like, my original plans.
And then the house.
Guys, I swear to god.
This is where I do the house thing.
That's why I've also been taking a lot of sponsors too.
Because I want to be...
Okay.
I legitimately forgot to fight this guy.
I swear today...
I think today's just like my extra off day.
And I want to create lots of happy memories with my drag wounds.
Okay.
Lots of happy memories.
Before it's gone.
Before my career dies.
Oh my god.
This stupid jock.
I want to stuff this man into a locker.
All right.
I'm focusing up now.
I'm not.
JK.
Bro, why is his clone...
So much easier.
Like...
Like, I swear to god.
I don't know how I fought the robot guy.
The clone.
It's because he was AI.
See guys?
AI will never be better than the original.
This proves it.
AI will never be better than the original, guys.
Okay.
Am I actually on her level?
Oh my god.
He's just stomping me.
He's just stepping on me.
But little does he know.
The dragon was like it.
Happens after that.
Jesus Christ.
Oh my god.
I know this other...
His second form, he grabs people.
So like, I'm fucked.
Like, if anything, I always get grabbed.
All right, guys.
This is it.
Put your appraisals in.
Put your...
Put your appraisals in, guys.
This is it.
This is our buffer appraisal time.
Rodrigo, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And then very soon.
Let's have lots of happy memories together.
Even while I'm suffering.
At least you're having a happy time, right?
What's next?
Godfrey, what's next?
What's named Godfrey?
I don't fucking know.
I'm just giving people random names.
It's Zangief time.
I've given thee courtesy enough.
Oh my god.
He's gonna grab me.
No, I know it.
I know he's gonna grab me.
I could feel...
I'm gonna get grabbed right here.
I don't even know when the cutscene's gonna end.
It's gonna end.
I won't know it.
And then I'm gonna get grabbed.
Now I fight just horror-lood.
Horror-lood.
Oh my god.
I fucking know.
Wow, it's like I predicted it.
It's like I predicted it, guys.
I would've thought.
I can't believe it's like a self-fulfilling prophecy.
I wrote the script.
Oh my god.
I can't believe I predicted it perfectly.
I knew my fate.
I knew what he was gonna do.
To my loyal fans.
The sim of life begins.
Thank you for the Hakasu.
But thank you.
Thank you.
It's like oh my...
It's like...
Oh my god.
I was just not ready.
You know what?
No, that was on me.
It's okay.
All right.
Okay.
Oh.
It's okay.
My child will be okay.
Oh my god.
Okay, but what about me?
What about me?
I'm also a child.
I'm also a child too.
You won't be okay.
Your child is okay though.
My child outlived me.
Good thing you were a king player in Tekken.
Also, this is the boss that made Nimi drop this game.
Wait, really?
Aztec, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
I feel like this boss is not friendly towards magic builds though.
In general, because he's like the charger.
I don't get it, but I watched all these other Elden Ring players play too.
How come I can't do the things they're doing?
Oh, I panic rolled.
I panic rolled, yes.
I want to make it like it's a corpo for 3D.
You know?
I don't want to half-ass it.
I want to have the best quality as I can.
Because the 3D concert was crazy.
Um, but I want to up that.
I want to do better than that.
I'll make it like, you know, the quality like I'm in the company.
Because I want to show like, you know, indies can do that too.
It's a lot of money, but we can do it too.
It's unfortunately a lot of money, but like, we can do it as well.
You sound drunk?
I'm just not mentally there.
Like, ever since Malakiep...
Ever since Malakiep, guys...
Like, the person in my mind is like, dead.
The body has been rotting in my head for like, a couple of hours now.
My broken from Malakiep.
Oh my god, he fucking no jumping.
He anti-aired me.
Jesus Christ, okay.
Okay.
I think the worst part is like, I can't see anything.
Like, I actually...
I legitimately just can't see anything.
I'm so blind.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I feel like there's like, a specific window where I can fight.
Oh, nice.
Okay, before he stepped on my head, I got...
I got the hit.
All right.
This is where he...
Okay, grabs me again.
Please, please, no!
Oh my god, oh my god, it's so delay, I don't like that, I don't like that.
Why is it so delay?
Why is it so mercy?
Mercy!
Oh my god!
Uncle Uncle!
It's always the delayed attacks.
Can we get something if we make it halfway to the girl?
Nextie, thank you for the Akasufa.
Thank you.
If we get halfway, I'll complete the game.
I'll complete the story bosses.
Bro.
Oh my god, I have never seen that move before.
Where did this move came from?
Oh my god, stop.
You were it?
No, it's just good, it's just good.
And the charity didn't say I was going to complete Elden Ring.
Oh my god, some of these moves I like don't know.
Like I know he's done that before, but he just doesn't do it often.
But he like fucks with me.
God, and the queen fucks...
Married this man?
No, why did she...
And like...
Why did she like divorce him?
I don't understand.
Why would you ever divorce...
How?
Oh, but just kill me.
I...
I don't care anymore.
I don't...
Just kill me.
Okay, Ben, no chickening out now.
I can't believe she's divorced him.
Oh my god.
Yeah, she like ended up fucking herself.
She was like...
That's...
That must hurt your ego, you know?
Like that must really fucking hurt your ego.
Your wife leaves you.
And then she was like...
You were such a bad husband.
I'd rather just fuck myself.
Like...
You were such a...
You were such a bad husband.
Like the...
Like bed was terrible.
Like I'd rather just fuck myself.
Like...
Yeah.
Don't do that to Godfrey.
Finish the game.
Yeah.
Oh yeah, no, I know about the whole...
She created like a male version of herself as a consort.
Like I know that.
There were...
It was like...
Like the Elden Ring shorts kept popping up in my algorithm.
So I got curious.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
I thought I dodged it.
But I guess not.
Oh my god.
Ramona, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Time to beat the game.
Uh...
Vinsta, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you, thank you.
Finish the game.
It is...
We get there?
Yeah, we got it.
All right.
At least we can finish...
We'll finish the game.
I promise you guys we'll finish the game.
Not today.
This is my last boss today.
And then I...
And then I need to find a new...
New brain cell to inhabit in my mind.
I gotta clean...
I gotta clean the body first.
And then I'm gonna take like applications.
On who wants to be my new brain cell.
I need to like dodge more I feel like.
Like I need to play more slow.
But yeah, cause he does so many moves.
And I feel like he just...
He's gotta not be so greedy.
Oh, shit.
Oh yeah, that's me being greedy.
I could have dodged that.
Oh no.
Okay.
Oh!
Wrong dodge.
Oh no.
No, no, no, no.
I spammed my attack too much.
Eh?
Oh no.
I thought he was gonna anti-air me.
He doesn't need to.
He doesn't...
He doesn't need to anti-air me.
He can just air...
Anti- me in general.
No, no, no, no, no!
No!
Oh, fuck!
Okay.
I'll give time for appraisals.
Yeah, boss is just an anti.
Yeah.
I literally have...
My brain is up for rent right now.
The last tenant has died.
All right, guys.
I have an idea.
Guys, it worked!
Holy shit.
It's okay.
At least that worked, you know?
Like...
Oh, shit.
Goodbye.
Oh my god, he slam-ducked me.
It's too late.
I got that one though, at least.
Okay, I might have got slam-ducked, but...
I got that working.
Oh no.
No, fuck.
No.
Oh my god, please.
I'm pretty- I'm pretty sick.
Please.
Holy shit.
That was crazy.
I didn't think you could do that.
Holy shit.
Oh.
Oh my god.
I don't want him to do that again.
Holy fuck.
Oh my god, he can't slam-duck on jellyfish.
That's okay.
He can't slam-duck on jellyfish.
He doesn't know how.
Oh my god.
I don't want them to do that again.
Please I praise this.
I praise this.
Please.
I praise it before it's too late.
It's okay.
Please.
Oh.
Holy shit.
Oh!
I'll die for poison!
It's fine!
Please, it's time for poison!
I got it!
Yay!
Caprio, we threw the slam dunk.
See, the streamer build has reigned supreme.
We did it, Jellyfish!
The concussion doesn't hurt nobody.
They can't concuss me when there's no one living in my head.
Well done.
The Jelly survived the whole time.
Can't concuss me when the person that lives there has died.
Oh my god!
Oh!
We did it!
Alright!
Do we do arcane?
Okay, what do we do, guys?
Yeah!
Oh my god!
No brain damage if no brain!
Wait, is the next boss the last one?
Is it the last one, chat?
Okay.
I'll...
You know what?
For you guys...
We'll finish... We'll finish Elden Ring today.
What?
For you guys...
We'll do it today.
We're gonna do arcane?
I don't think he bleeds, though.
That's the thing.
Can we do Dexterity?
Wait...
And then what?
Endurance?
How about this?
Is that fine?
Okay.
Dexterity, is this okay?
Alright.
I guess it's time.
Wait, maybe I have enough...
Wait, actually, how much do I need?
To level up again?
Uh...
60.
Do I have the thing?
Okay, if I do one more, it should be enough.
Alright.
That should be enough now.
No, I can't use all of it.
Because if I use all of it, I don't even level up.
Alright, what do we get the last one?
Guys, the last one.
Oh, true!
I could munch my boss souls.
You're right.
I don't have to fight Melania.
You're...
Yeah!
You're so right, guys.
Okay, we'll do Endurance after...
Okay.
You're right.
I can eat them all.
Say goodbye.
Bye.
Say goodbye to everybody, guys.
It's time...
To rage bait one last time.
Alright.
Okay.
Let's see.
No better time.
You're right.
Okay, we'll do all of this first before I start my last rage bait.
Goodbye.
Fire giant.
Wait.
Goodbye.
Crafted.
Yum-yum-yum!
Goodbye, Starscrooge!
Yum-yum-yum-yum!
Goodbye, Omen King!
Tasty-tasty sauce!
Goodbye, Black Blade!
Yum-yum-yum!
And finally, the last Rage Bait.
Aura Koralu!
Goodbye, Koralu!
I've broken many Elder Ring players today.
If I'm gonna get mine broken...
If I get mine broken, I'm bringing down as many Elder Ring players down with me.
Let that girl eat!
Eat glass!
Thank you, the Akka Soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Hopefully this helps, even though we didn't make it to the goal.
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
That's right!
Ha ha ha ha!
Okay!
We do Vigor, Endurance, Dexterity.
Is that good?
Chet?
I am the God-Devouring Servers.
I am the one that devours.
Ha ha ha ha!
Is that good, or do we want more?
I logged on!
Ha ha ha ha!
Which is like, that's it!
How could you eat all those souls?
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha!
Alright, here we go.
After I ate all the souls, they left.
Alright, this is it.
Hello, I shall become the Eldenor.
Hello.
Oh yeah, I'm gonna kill the hus- Oh my god, that's so fucked up.
The ex-husband was there to protect the husband.
I forgot to- Ooh, I didn't realize I had 58k runes.
Mind break, where is the sweat?
Yo, thank you for the super chat.
I did not realize I had 58k.
That's actually so fucked up.
You force your ex-husband to protect your new husband.
Witches yourself.
Goodbye, runes.
Yeah, his wife, boyfriend.
Whoa.
It's causing my controller to vibrate.
God, that mac and cheese is gonna hit good tonight.
I should've let people know I was finishing Elden Ring today.
I didn't even know how much I had left.
He'll be like, man, how come we never got an Elden Ring stream after that?
Yeah.
I didn't even know, guys.
How close we were.
Alright.
Hello.
Okay.
Can you bleed anyway?
I don't even know.
This is it, Dragooops.
The second final fight.
You think I don't know he turns into a flying dragon?
I didn't like...
Ha ha ha ha.
Guys, I know what happens afterwards.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
No, I know he's immune to bleed.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
I have an army.
They're not immune to poison.
Whoa.
Okay.
The hardest part is...
...the last boss, though.
For sure.
It's fine.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh my god.
How was I supposed to do?
Actually...
I never get critical hit because I'm too stupid.
I'm too scared.
All right, the actual fight time.
Oh my god, this is the actual fight.
We need more appraisals.
All right, the real fight.
All right, here he goes.
Hello, little guy.
Here comes daddy.
What even is he, anyway?
All right.
Lore droppers.
Drop the lore.
There was a name for you guys, right?
Loremen.
People of the lore.
Oh yeah, there is.
Nerds.
Nerds!
Drop the lore.
He's Jesus.
Hello.
I'm so tiny compared to him.
Am I doing it?
Am I- Am I doing it?
I can't tell.
Guys, I don't think I was doing it there.
Oh my god.
Am I doing it?
What am I...
Like, what?
Oh my god.
I think I fucked that up.
Okay.
I don't think that was how I was supposed to ride.
Torrent.
Okay.
Oh, I thought I could dodge that.
He's so far.
Torrent's so gone now.
Oh my god.
I just made it to you.
So fucked up.
I just got to you, too.
How is my jellyfish- Oh, he's gonna die here.
I'm gonna save that and then he's gonna die here.
Why is this attack?
How is this gonna fuck me up?
That's the question.
Oh.
Oh, that's out.
Okay.
I just run away?
Oh, I see.
I shall kill the space.
Oh my god.
What?
The three- I- He- The timing fucked me up.
Oh my god.
I messed up one timing and then it was over for me.
It was over.
Yeah.
I messed up that timing and then it messed up all my other timing.
Alright, it's time.
It's time.
All in.
All in, guys.
This is it.
This is our final stat.
This is our final stat, everyone.
What?
We're going all in.
All of us.
Right here.
We shall reign supreme.
Our final stat.
Oh wait, what?
Where's Maiden?
Guide.
Alright.
And then the last one.
This is our final stat.
Right here.
We did it.
We're gonna do it.
Together, Dragoons.
Me, you and I, and the streamer build.
This is it.
We shall prove them all.
The power of the streamer build, everyone.
Oh my god.
He used a new attack right away.
I have never seen that attack.
I mean, not new, sorry.
I have not seen him use that so early before.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm not okay.
I think my first attempt might be my best attempt.
Oh my god.
I'm so sorry, child.
I am so sorry, child.
I'm so sorry.
You lived longer in the other tribe.
Oh my god.
I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Okay.
That's a deleted attack.
At least I know.
Oh, he came back for me!
He jumped up at my jellyfish and then came back to me.
Oh my god.
I got baited so hard.
I got baited.
I have to blow my nose.
All right.
Holy shit.
Here we go.
What about DLC?
Think of the content, man.
Min.
That's for another charity goal.
Oh my god.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Got a healer.
Nice.
Wait, what is that?
What is that?
Oh, the delay.
I feel like he does like...
This guy does so many delay attacks.
It's...
He fucks with me so much.
Okay.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, there's...
That's a grid.
Okay.
Okay, now I know.
Oh my god, I got my first critical hit thing.
I've never been so lucky before.
What?
Okay.
That was cute.
I thought I hit that.
That sucks.
I hit that.
I didn't hit that.
Oh my god, I didn't hit that either.
Okay, that's good.
Just focus on my child.
Okay.
Okay, I can't die.
Okay, guys.
All right.
It's appraisal time.
Oh!
All right, we're gonna give a little stall.
We're gonna give a little stall before we go straight in.
I don't need to score in there.
Oh my god.
He is so...
What did he do to my jellyfish?
Okay.
Oh, my jellyfish was like full HP.
What?
Okay.
I don't know how to dodge that.
All right, goodbye.
I don't need to charge it to the distance.
Okay.
Goodbye, Torrent.
I don't know how to use Torrent effectively, guys.
He was not there for the longest time.
Oh my god.
Goodbye, Torrent.
Wait.
No.
No!
This!
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, I could jump the circles?
Okay, that's good to know.
Because I definitely did not know.
Oh my god.
Okay, I swear to god, I pressed circles.
I'll never be able to hit him.
Okay.
I know the timing for that.
I think.
I'm gonna say that and I'm gonna fuck it up.
I couldn't feel it.
Oh my god.
I don't know the timing for that.
I don't...
Oh!
I don't know the timing for that.
It's so slow!
Yeah.
That timing is so slow.
Do I have Holy Resist Talisman?
I do!
Because I haven't looked at my stuff in a long time.
No.
Alright.
There we go.
Come on, guys.
Dragoons strong together.
Dragoons strong together!
The streamer build hell supreme!
Guys!
For the streamer build!
Oh, shit!
Oh my god.
Okay, that one was on me.
I got greedy.
I got so greedy there.
Holy shit!
That was the fastest I've ever died of them.
I got so greedy.
I got greedy once and it fucked me up.
It fucked me over.
No, I know you can't bleed, but I don't really have any other weapon.
This is my best weapon.
I could put poison on.
Wait, I could...
I'm gonna change my...
Um...
I'll put...
Put that here.
Guess I don't have a frost sword.
It's too late.
Okay, that's fine.
Oh no.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Yeah.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Fuck.
No.
No!
Oh the...
The strength!
Okay.
Are you serious you fucker?
Oh my god.
That fucking sucked.
I hate my depth perception.
Oh, no!
That was close.
Not get the, wait, is that not the... no this is, this is the poison.
Wait, actually, it's 175.
Should I use the poison blade, or no?
Or keep the rivers of blood?
Okay.
I don't think I can.
Do I have upgrades?
Do I have enough Sombra stones?
No, I don't have any more stones.
I used them all up.
I was so hungry.
I was so hungry, guys.
I don't know.
I think it is.
This one is, like, really...
I know I just used it, but I was like... I don't know if this is worth it.
I feel like... I'm just going to swap back.
I like the other ability more.
Alright.
Oh my god!
I feel like the amount of time I said it does that, and I just forgot.
I just forgot.
I was like, it does that?
And then he does it, like, 20 times, and I'm still like, it does that, guys?
Oh my god, I literally rolled into it.
Oh!
Oh my god, I'm rolling into it.
Oh my god!
Please.
Please, I don't deserve this.
I don't deserve this abuse.
What is he trying to hit?
Oh my god!
That fucking range.
Is better to break skill?
Sans?
Okay, I'll try that.
I'll try... I'll try... I'll swap my swords.
I'll start... I'll swap it one more time.
Alright.
That is such a fucking huge range.
Yeah, he instant transmissioned me.
You know what would make this bot easier?
Unlocking the exclusive Dill Keeper lane by using the link in the pin chat.
Sorry to get only 364 at night, night.
Solid Snake, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it.
Thanks for helping me, Shell.
Alright.
Yeah.
Guys, I think I lost all the drag wounds that were appraising me.
I think... I think...
I think they're all gods.
They've all died in the war.
I've been waiting for the appraisal for 60 years.
They've all died.
The women, the children, the elderly.
All the men, God.
Thank you for your service.
They're so tired.
We're running out of drag...
They all died.
I am fighting the one drag wound so strong.
Please.
We need more children.
How do we make more children when all of them are dead?
I'm so tired, bot.
Oh, shit.
He's slowly walking.
Oh, my God.
Never mind.
He's not slowly walking over anymore.
Oh, my God.
I hate that.
Oh, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho, ho.
I've never seen that move before.
Oh, my God.
That's new.
Jesus.
He is so...
I can't get to his other form anymore.
I feel like he's learning.
Oh, my God.
I'm trying to...
Jesus Christ.
Holy shit.
Oh, wait.
I'm gonna get water real quick.
I ran out of water.
I'll try it.
I got up and I was like...
I got the water.
Okay.
I'm locking in.
Oh.
I'm locking in now.
I got at least...
I got to get my groove back.
I feel like if I don't sink, I do better.
I'll put some new ones.
Don't worry, I got you.
There you go.
I'm getting lazier.
There.
The one appraisal.
Don't worry.
I got you.
I say yes.
I put one appraisal down.
Okay.
I'm locking in now.
Jesus.
I need to remember that that is the...
Oh, my God.
He just anti-aired me.
Just like that.
Jesus.
Okay.
What?
I swear to God.
I don't see like half of the moves that he's doing.
Like he's actually using new stuff.
No, no, no, no, no.
Nice.
Okay, that's good.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Not at me.
What is that delay?
What the fu- Oh, my God.
That's actually bullshit.
Bullshit.
I...
Oh, my God.
He had so many delays.
There's so...
It's cause like I feel...
I keep thinking it's like the instant hit, but not the delay hit.
And then I start panic rolling because of it.
Don't worry, guys.
I will refill it.
No turn your shithead.
I'm refilling the messages, guys.
Don't worry.
Reload.
Alright.
Oh.
Pilargus.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please, I swear.
I'll get better.
I know it's been a while since we beat phase one.
But I swear to God, I'll get better.
Okay.
I'm just gonna use my...
Oh, Sarah.
Thank you for the rain.
Thank you.
Come on.
No!
Okay.
I got that rolling.
Oh, my God.
I didn't get that though.
It's okay.
My child.
Oh, my God.
You sacrificed yourself for me.
I swear to God, you won't die in vain.
Nevermind.
Oh.
Okay.
We might have died in vain.
Oh.
We might...
We might have disappointed my child.
But it's okay.
It's okay.
Alright.
This time, we'll lock in.
This time we lock in, for real.
Look at all these blood splatters, they're 90% me.
Guys, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Well, we're sort of, like, degrading the longer we go.
We haven't seen the other guy in a long time.
I don't know, I feel like that's bad.
Guys, remember when we would, like, first try, like, I don't know what happened, guys.
I
remember.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Pounding game!
Every time, my head just, my head can't comprehend.
Every time, my head just sees he holds it for, like, four seconds longer.
And then my... my brain short-circuits... I short-circuit there.
No, no, we can do it.
I believe... we can do it.
No, no.
Alright.
Mama raised no quitter.
No.
This is fine.
We ain't no quitter.
My brain cell didn't die in vain.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Guys, I miss when everybody would appraise me.
We definitely ran out of appraisals, guys.
Oh my god, you turned around?!
That's fucked up.
You turned around.
Okay.
No, I wanted to TP!
Alright, we back up here.
And then we back up there, and then we keep backing up because he's like a little scary.
And then he misses.
That's fine.
Okay.
Are you serious?
That's fucked up.
Okay.
Oh my god.
No!
That's not fair!
He...
My jellyfish fucking...
Oh my god.
My jellyfish...
Broke the stance.
I can't believe my jellyfish got the fucking stagger.
Oh my god.
I guess I'll boot up the game on my second PC.
We'll get there eventually.
That's sad.
The jellyfish is the main character now.
Oh my god.
That's not what I want to do.
I might buy like a wireless controller.
Because I'm...
Oh my god.
I'm not feeling it.
The future fucking...
The wire is pissing me off.
Oh my god.
I...
I'm so sad.
I didn't anticipate...
Oh my god.
Okay.
What?
How do you get out of that?
Oh my god.
He actually comboed me.
No, no, no, no, no.
Not again.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
Oh, I jump.
Now I know.
I just gotta jump.
Jesus.
Okay.
Me and my child were on a little road trip.
Honestly, worst road trip of my life.
I feel like he's just...
He's getting better.
And I'm like...
I've peaked in high school.
He's actually...
He's learning.
I'm helping this AI learn.
I...
Oh my god.
He turns around.
Because of course he does.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, child.
Your death won't be in vain.
I swear to god for real this time.
Oh my god.
There we go.
I'm feeding the AI right now.
Alright.
I don't know if we're gonna win this, but like...
Tape is everything.
Why can't we be friends.
Why can't we be friends?
He can do that?!
What?!
I'm...
What's going...
Guys, guys.
Appraise me.
Please, please!
We can't appraise this!
We can live through all of this!
What did he do?!
I swear I've never seen that move before.
Oh, what the fuck happened there?
Holy shit.
It was a power appraisal as we lived.
I don't know how.
Oh my god.
We definitely didn't deserve to.
Okay.
It's a rare move.
That's cool.
Because of course... Because of course he'll use the rare move on me.
Oh my god.
Every time I get closer.
What is that?
Oh!
I guess there I go.
Okay.
I don't know how to do this jump thing.
Like...
Guys, did I do it?
Guys, do you think I did it?
Do you think I did something?
Oh my... I'm not okay.
I don't know how to do it.
Jump, girl.
Jump.
No, I have Torrin.
But like... I... I don't know how to efficiently use him.
That's the issue.
Every time I use Torrin, I fuck up.
So at that point, I've given up.
No, I deserve that.
No.
Okay.
Oh my god!
Alright, that's fine.
Maybe I don't deserve Torrin.
You're right.
I don't deserve my horse.
Okay, let's try this.
Okay.
Maybe we can do it.
I believe.
How do I get off my horse efficiently, guys?
It's not like that.
Barely not like that, guys.
Oh my god.
What is going on?!
Just like that.
Okay.
What's going on?
I don't know what this is.
Oh.
Guys, guys.
What's going on?
What's going on?!
What the fuck is going on?!
I'm at the end!
He took me to the end!
How is that possible?!
I don't know what's going on.
I don't know half the moves he's using.
I feel like it's not good that he took me so far out here.
Guys, I don't think I can...
I don't know if I can do this one.
Right.
Oh!
I was going to say, I did it!
Guys, I didn't do it.
I didn't do it!
I was going to be like, guys, I did it!
Guys, I didn't do it.
I was so hopeful.
What the fuck happened to me?!
Oh my god!
Okay.
I'll get here eventually, guys.
Oh my god, I made it.
I made it!
Oh no, guys, guys, guys, guys, guys!
Please!
Okay.
Oh god, that was scary.
Guys, I made it.
Never mind.
I guess I'll never make it.
I can't!
Okay.
I'll get there eventually, sir.
Please, just wait up.
Can you wait for me, please?
Oh!
Not like that, though.
Please, not like that.
Oh no, I'm fucking dead.
I'm dead.
Last upgrade.
Last, last heal.
Oh my god!
I don't know how to dodge that!
I never got that far!
Oh!
Oh my god, please.
No!
Guys!
We did it!
Oh, save me!
Save!
Oh, the power of the streamer build!
Oh my god!
We fucking did it!
With the power of the streamer build!
Oh my god!
Okay.
Time for it!
We did it!
We finally...
Oh my god!
We became John Elden Ring!
Touch...
Mend the Elden Ring!
Oh my god!
Now that these bursts...
100Message of phrases!
The newrd message of phrases!
Do you think I did it?
Oh my god!
It's time to get that head, guys!
We've been trying for so long!
No!
Linden Ring!
Thank you, this super chat banana!
Thank you!
We did it.
The strongest build in the Elden Ring.
Recyclement.
Thank you for the Akka Supa.
Thank you.
The strongest build.
Mind size.
Thank you to the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on beating the game Tokyo Capital.
We did it.
We actually beat the game.
I didn't think I was this close to the ending.
Me and my 4000 dragoons.
I have an army.
On us.
And recall.
That's me.
An age.
Of fracture.
And have no maidens.
So my armor is my maiden now.
I don't need no maidens.
I can touch myself.
That's me.
I'm the Elden Lord.
Yay!
My armor can touch me.
Oh.
Thank God.
We did it.
What a ride.
I did not think we were going to beat Elden Ring today.
But we did.
I'm so tired.
I'm going to treat myself with some good ass mac and cheese.
Yippee.
We...
Oh.
That was fun.
What a wild ride.
Chat.
What a fucking rile...
Blah.
Can't even English.
What a wild journey.
To the end.
The thing is.
I...
I didn't know.
How...
Close we were.
To beating Elden Ring.
I had two more thumbnails made.
In advance.
I...
I had two more thumbnails.
Made in advance.
Because I thought we had so much more Elden Ring left.
So like...
Whoops.
Tell us.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome...
That's for the DLC.
Let's see.
Oh.
That's another charity.
Cool.
Um...
But yeah.
Thank you guys.
My brain is so tired now.
I didn't think I'd be...
I mean...
I was gonna stream.
Wait.
How long was I streaming for?
Oh my gosh.
I didn't think I'd do a 3 hour stream today.
Because I did another 2 hour already.
This morning.
Um...
But thank you guys.
Look.
Guys.
Under 200 deaths with me.
I'm so tired.
But...
It was a...
Wild ride.
It was a great journey with all my dragoons.
Thank you everybody for...
The Akasufas.
I really, really do...
Appreciate it guys.
Thank you everyone for the support and everything.
And for...
Helping me...
Uh...
Fundraise for...
My...
Um...
3D...
Debut.
I really appreciate it guys.
Um...
Solid Snake.
Thank you for the Akasufa.
Thank you.
Here's my very first ever Akka.
Congrats on becoming the...
Praise Elden Braid.
This is not only because you beat the game.
But also because I know you will make an amazing event with this.
Like always.
Amazing job Doki.
Rest well.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Akasufa.
Um...
But yes.
I don't wanna like hype it up too much.
But I'm trying...
I wanna make a really good stream for you guys.
Cause you've been waiting for so long.
For the 3D debut.
So...
Um...
Thank you guys so much for...
Uh...
Supporting me.
Um...
But this will be my...
I swear to god.
That will be my last big investment.
That will be the last one.
And then after that...
There will be...
There will be smaller things.
I swear.
This is the last one.
This will be like...
My last...
Big...
My biggest project...
Ever.
And then like...
And then we'll...
We'll...
We'll save for...
An apartment.
Um...
Courteous!
Thank you for our Magenta Soupa!
Thank you!
I love good streams.
Thank you guys.
Thank you." I really appreciate it.
Thank you everybody.
Um...
Technically, I can... I can afford it, like the 3D, but I just want to make sure that, you know, just to be safety, you know, just to safety after I spent that money.
Thank you.
What a long, long journey, guys.
We had a long journey today.
Um, I am, I am like, uh, yeah.
Like, it's that cushion.
Yeah, yeah.
It's the cushion for me.
Yeah.
But thank you, guys.
We, we yelled at each other.
We made up.
And then we yelled at each other again.
There were threats.
There were negotiations.
There were bribes.
Um, there was executions.
But in the end, the streamer build reigned supreme, guys.
In the end, the streamer build succeeded yet again.
There was hostage situation.
There was extortion.
There was everything.
This Elden Ring playthrough had everything, guys.
Uh, ha ha ha.
There was even a rebellion that I managed to squash.
So, yay.
Ha ha ha.
And in the end, we proved to everybody that when we all work together, when we all work together, we can triumph and take on the world.
when we stop arguing.
When we...
Ha ha ha.
But thank you, everybody.
I am...
I am EP now.
Um, Jordan, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Ha ha ha.
It's okay, because we're both abusing each other.
It's balanced, guys.
It's a...
It's a balanced relationship.
Because the abuse goes both ways.
Ha ha ha.
Anyway...
Anyway, guys...
Um, I...
Is there an after-credits scene?
No, that is not fine, Toki.
Guys, guys, is there an after-credits scene?
Guys?
This is giving me PTSD.
It's very healthy, guys.
This is very healthy.
Is there an after-credits scene, chat?
No?
Alright, guys, I'm gonna peace out now.
Thank you, everyone!
I would do an after- I would do a Zazzadon, but...
I'm gonna be- I'm gonna be my head tired.
Um, but tomorrow- Tomorrow, there is a stream for- on Twitch.
Tomorrow's stream is on Twitch, by the way.
For the Fate Trigger Tournament.
It's on Twitch.
So, um, I'll see you guys there.
Next week, I will take a- At least four days off.
I'll take four days off next week to recharge myself.
Um, but, as always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed, cause you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everyone.
Bye, guys!
Bye!